hey girls I'm Jason I'm an eighth grader
at Joel Peterson middle school and I was
wondering why do people have favourites
if our brains all presumably grow the
same shouldn't we all have the same
favourites aren't we all the same donor
our brains all grow the same the answer
is no and yes that is to say we have
much more like we are much more alike
than we are different
this old question if I see red is it the
same to you as it is to me like what I
think is red is really green and your
brain learns to call what your green is
my red and so on okay these are good
questions but I think the reason we have
favourites is that we all are slightly
different we do not look identical
we are not biological clones everybody
is a little different everybody is
exposed to different experiences and
different chemicals different things in
the air and water as you grow up so what
you prefer and food could change from
one place to another based on your
environment and everybody's genes are
different the one exception might be
identical twins but everybody's genes
are different and so what we prefer what
we like what we find as favorites is
different from one person to another but
if nothing else I have learned in life
people are a heck of a lot more alike
than they are different you'll find that
if you like a yummy chocolate dessert
it's very likely that someone else will
like that yummy chocolate dessert that
your favorites you'll beat you may be
surprised are favored by a great many
people when you get into disagreements
it's often I think a result of your
experiences like I have had great
experiences eating ice cream with honey
vanilla ice cream with honey every time
I think about it I think about my dad
and I have good thoughts but there's
other people who think vanilla ice cream
that's not interesting enough to me
the honey that's too commonplace no I
won't say I feel bad for you but that
means more vanilla and honey for me that
you'll find people more alike than they
are different and enjoy the favorite
celebrate these little differences it's
a part of what makes life fun carry on
[Music]